talking about foreign policy here a
little bit there's corruption on both
sides I mean Jared Kushner was
negotiating better weapons deals for
Saudi Arabia all right that's a lot of
corruption there with with North Korea
John Bolton sabotaged any possibilities
of peace talks by comparing North Korea
saying that they're going into the
Libyan model of foreign policy but again
you could always compare the two but I I
think it's fair to say that
um the Biden presidency has a lot more
room for corruption because he's a
career politician he's been in office he
knows everyone he knows all the
diplomats he knows all the bureaucrats
he has a lot more finagling room to do a
lot of really bad stuff and from the
beginning of his political career he has
been known as a man of the lobbyist he
has been giving a lot of special
interest groups a lot of what they
wanted uh specifically the
military-industrial complex specifically
big Pharma specifically a lot of the
bigger agencies that are now coming in
through the bigger problems that he
caused